[Applaudissements]
vous êtes une incroyable machine
et je rêve de vous comprendre
vous l'avez compris on va parler
d'intelligence artificielle enfin pas
exactement quand on y pense
l'intelligence c'est sur côté non mais
c'est vrai vos amis sont pas vos amis
parce qu'ils sont intelligents si vos
amis sont vos amis c'est parce qu'ils se
comporte bien avec vous
et pareil si vous admirez une personne
c'est pas tant pour son intelligence que
pour ce qu'elle a fait voire même ce
qu'elle ferait
ce que l'on juge chez l'autre ce n'est
pas l'intelligence c'est le comportement
de toute façon intelligence ça se
définit même pas très bien on pourrait
parler de quotient intellectuel ou des 8
à 12 types d'intelligence selon les
sources mais tout ça est beaucoup trop
fou pour un scientifique
par contre un comportement c'était fini
très bien c'est tout simplement une
fonction un lien entre ce que l'on
observe et ce que l'on fait
autrement dit c'est comment nous allons
réagir dans n'importe quelle situation
en tant que chercheur ou qu'un génial je
ne cherche pas à construire des machines
intelligentes je cherche à construire
des machines qui se comportent bien
donc on va plutôt parler de comportement
artificiel et nous allons voir à quel
point est-ce que votre comportement fait
de vous une incroyable machine
pour ça on va passer par trois grands
domaines scientifiques l'apprentissage
l'algorithmique et l'automatique
dans ces trois domaines qui sont
étrangement indépendants alors qui
traitent du même sujet j'ai pu étudier
le comportement artificiel sous des
angles bien différents
et par extension un petit peu le
comportement des humains aussi
lorsqu'on parle d'intelligence
artificielle aujourd'hui la plupart des
ingénieurs entendent apprentissage
statistique ou machine learning alors
que l'apprentissage ne fait qu'étudier
la question comment prendre de
meilleures décisions à partir
d'expériences passées ou de donner si
vous préférez
et ça pour moi ça correspond exactement
à ce qu'on appelle l'intuition
grâce à nos expériences on est capable
de se construire une intuition qu'on est
souvent pas capable d'expliquer mais qui
va nous permettre de prendre rapidement
des bonnes décisions dans des situations
très complexes par exemple si tu as Sion
très complexe
sur cette image vous êtes normalement
capable de reconnaître un chat
posez-vous la question comment vous
faites
non mais vraiment essayez de vous
expliquer à vous-même comment vous voyez
un chat là
vous dites sûrement bah c'est facile il
a des oreilles de chat des pattes de
chat donc c'est un chat quoi
ok alors maintenant expliquez-moi
pourquoi est-ce que ça c'est une oreille
de chat et pas ça
pas si facile
pourtant on est capable aujourd'hui
d'apprendre à une machine ce qu'est une
image de chat pour ça on va lui montrer
des exemples d'images de chat non chat
et on va lui faire construire une
intuition de ce qu'est une image de chat
et je parle d'intuition parce que très
souvent on est incapable d'expliquer
comment l'algorithme fait
on sait comment il a appris on sait
comment il est calcule mais l'algo
serait incapable de nous expliquer
comment il fait tout comme nous en fait
mais on n'a pas attendu d'avoir des
données pour essayer de prendre les
meilleures décisions dans n'importe
quelle situation
revenons un peu dans le temps
nous sommes le 11 mai 1997
Internet et déployé en France depuis
seulement 3 ans
et le format DVD vient à peine de sortir
aux États-Unis
Garric
champion du monde des échecs depuis déjà
12 années consécutives et considéré
comme un génie un des hommes les plus
intelligents de son époque
aujourd'hui il sort d'un match qui
marquera l'histoire il vient d'être
vaincu par Deep Blue d'IBM une machine
et là le monde tremble
ça y est Terminator avait raison le
soulèvement des machines arrivent elles
sont devenues plus intelligentes que
nous
ce jour-là à défaut d'avoir créé Skynet
IBM montra qu'un simple algorithme qu'on
voit d'ailleurs ici en première année à
centrale Supélec combiné à de la
puissance de calcul nous permet de
vaincre le champion des échecs de
l'humanité
pour moi utilisez un algorithme c'est
faire preuve de réflexion c'est calculer
consciemment les possibilités et
chercher la meilleure solution
et c'est très puissant un algorithme
vous permet d'obtenir la meilleure
réponse à chaque fois et ce sans donner
sans expérience
pourtant
Terminator n'est pas arrivé aujourd'hui
et c'est certainement pas grâce à notre
éthique
donc c'est peut-être que les algorithmes
sont plus limités que ce que l'on pense
une première limite à la puissance de
calcul en utilisant le même algorithme
mais sur un autre jeu le jeu de Go qui
est très similaire aux échecs mais avec
10 fois plus d'actions possibles par
coup on estime qu'il faudrait attendre
au moins 2030 pour avoir la puissance de
calcul nécessaire pour vaincre un humain
une autre limite et le simple fait qu'au
fond un algorithme c'est juste une
recette de cuisine
par exemple prenons la première étape de
la recette des crêpes
mettre dans un saladier de la farine
pour qu'une machine soit capable de
faire ça faudrait déjà qu'elle soit
capable de reconnaître la farine du
sucre et du sel et là on retombe sur le
problème de l'image de chat
c'est quoi les étapes élémentaires pour
pouvoir
savoir si n'importe quelle contient de
la farine ou une oreille de chat
pas on n'a pas réussi à trouver dans des
dizaines d'années de recherche et c'est
bien pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on fait ça
par apprentissage
pour nos crêpes notre algorithme notre
recette
elle va nous permettre d'obtenir nos
meilleures crêpes et ce à chaque fois
même si on a aucune expérience
mais on est obligé de prémâcher les
détails de simplifier le travail de
notre algorithme en séparant les
ingrédients à l'avance on est obligé de
le mettre dans une situation connue où
les étapes élémentaires sont claires
sinon il est perdu
la plupart des gens qui font
l'intelligence artificielle vous diront
que ça y est on a fait le tour et qu'il
s'agit simplement de combiner intuition
et réflexion pour obtenir une machine
aussi capable que nous
pourtant
quand vous conduisez une voiture ou que
vous jouez du piano
où que vous essayez de retourner une
crêpe
vous n'utilisez pas que votre réflexion
et votre intuition la plupart du temps
vous n'avez aucune idée de où sont vos
pieds vos mains et encore moins vos
doigts
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
souvenez-vous lorsque vous appreniez
vous deviez réfléchir consciemment à
comment placer vos mains puis c'est
devenu plus intuitif jusqu'à un moment
où vous n'aviez même plus à y penser
c'est devenu un réflexe un automatisme
et il y a une science entièrement
consacrée à cette question comment
donner des automatismes aux machines
l'automatique
l'automatique est à la base de la
majorité des mondes des machines de
notre monde moderne
elle permet d'apporter la stabilité et
que ce soit un métro ou un missile sans
garantie de stabilité
mais vite fait de s'en servir
donc admettons que nous avons ces trois
domaines donc
apprentissage algorithmique et
automatique qui correspondent à trois
façons bien distinctes de prendre des
décisions par intuition réflexion et par
automatisme
en quoi sommes-nous vraiment différents
des machines
si je vous ai dit que vous étiez
incroyable machine va bien avoir une
raison
cette raison ça pourrait être que ces
trois domaines sont vraiment trop isolés
pour se mélanger et qu'on soit incapable
de faire une machine hybride
sauf que pas du tout évidemment
l'automatique et l'algorithmique étant
les premières arrivées les ingénieurs
ont eu tout le temps de expérimenter des
hybrides sous toutes leurs formes
et en fait
d'un ascenseur a une fusée spatiale la
majorité des machines de notre monde
moderne est une combinaison de réflexion
pour le calcul de trajectoire pour la
planification long terme ou pour le
choix entre différentes options
et
d'automatisme pour apporter de la
stabilité garantir que le système
fonctionne correctement
plus récemment on commence à hybrider
l'apprentissage avec les autres domaines
d'abord avec l'algorithmique
en 2017 un algorithme a pris une
renommée mondiale en vainquant lycéol
champion du monde de GO alors que
rappelez-vous on pensait ça impossible
avant au moins 2030
cet algorithme c'est alphago par
dickmind
alphago est capable d'utiliser son
intuition entraîné sur des parties
d'experts
pour trier les coûts intéressants qu'il
va ensuite analyser par réflexion
à l'ancienne
cette combinaison d'intuition et de
réflexion ça a été contre toute attente
suffisant pour vaincre le champion du
monde de Go et ce avec beaucoup moins de
puissance de calcul que de la réflexion
pure et bien sûr on est aussi capable
d'ibrider l'apprentissage avec
l'automatique
en combinant les deux on obtient ça
mais si ça là
quand je suis devant vous sur scène en
train de parler j'ai pas tant que ça a
besoin de réfléchir par contre j'ai
besoin d'utiliser mon intuition pour
savoir quoi faire de mon corps et mes
réflexes pour pas tomber par terre
un parfait exemple
de cette hybride et
la robotique humanoïde
qu'est-ce qu'il y a ça vous fait peur
rappelez-vous ce que construit un
ingénieur ce n'est pas une intelligence
c'est un comportement
et finalement bien sûr on est aussi
capable de brider les trois un exemple
moins spectaculaire mais beaucoup plus
utile et une station d'épuration
autonome il y a des contraintes et de la
planification long terme à faire par
réflexion
il y a un environnement complexe en
amont de la station auquel il faut
s'adapter
par apprentissage
et il y a des machines et des composants
chimiques qui doivent être stables
par automatiquement
autrement dit c'est un parfait mélange
des trois comme de plus en plus de
projets à cette échelle en fait
mais alors
si nous ingénieurs sont déjà capables de
construire des machines n'importe où
dans le triangle
pourquoi tout travail n'est pas déjà
automatisé
est-ce que c'est juste une question de
temps
et bien je pense que
l'humain est encore aujourd'hui au delà
des frontières des machines
non pas grâce à nos émotions ça c'est un
autre sujet
mais pour le simple fait qu'une fois
placé quelque part dans ce triangle une
machine reste
elle est bloquée là précisément et c'est
tout
vous vous êtes capable de vous déplacer
dans ce triangle
vous
vous êtes capable de vous adapter à
n'importe quelle situation de notre
monde réel
et ce peu importe la difficulté
et pourtant
vu que notre monde n'a jamais été aussi
complexe il est très facile de s'y
sentir impuissant
dans ces moments de doute rappelez-vous
que aujourd'hui vous êtes la seule
machine
capable de surmonter cette complexité
la seule machine qui peut changer le
monde c'est vous car oui vous êtes une
incroyable machine
[Applaudissements]